the cool thing about these notebooks too
is you can make your ideas
come to life
[Music]
what's up gq i'm zach king and these are
my essentials
[Music]
legos legos have always been a huge part
of my life i have a pretty extensive
lego collection both at office
and my studio space and there's actually
a term
i'm technically an athol which is an
adult fan of legos
for me legos are therapeutic it's like
the thing i enjoy coming home from a
busy day
and i think what i enjoy about it is
actually going through the manual and
being told what to do i've kind of
realized over the years
following directions i get to enjoy and
do in the lego process
the rest of my life we're usually
creating the directions as filmmakers
one of my favorite series that they have
is the architect series and i bought all
of them and i buy them as i go but i
don't build them
until i go visit that city so it's a fun
thing when you see it in my office
that it's built that means i've been to
sydney or wherever
i love building sets that mean something
to me like the movie theater here i got
this when i was in high school when i
went down to film school
it represented like kind of the career
path that i was off to
i probably will never be making movies
for the big screen but
you know here i am making movies for
little devices for millions of people so
it's a different different world
[Music]
this is another essential item this is
the flamethrower by the boring company
and a lot of people have commented that
it's not technically a flamethrower but
i don't care it's still super cool i
actually found it more
practical than i ever thought one it's
super entertaining for my kids it buys
me about 30 minutes of parent time which
if when you're a parent of
two kids under three years old you know
that's a lot of time we'll make
marshmallows and s'mores
i've also used this to help cook and
some things you can do with desserts
like creme brulee is burning the top
it's really handy let's see if it just
[Music]
burning the mic
i don't think that's supposed to be
leaking i'll have to report that to elon
[Music]
this is one of my 3d printers and the
reason the 3d printer is really handy
for me and my
studio team is it allows the
brainstorming and the ideas to be really
limitless because we know we can 3d
print it most likely
so if we're talking about a concept
where we need a trash can that's an
exact specific size
that comes with a cute little bag we can
print it out and
spray paint it silver or whatever needs
to be i did a trick once where i i
was playing catch with myself and
tossing the football and then it turned
into a mini football in the foreground
and we'll take a regular football
eventually we scale it down to the right
size and we paint it and it's just a
really cute miniature
[Music]
it also comes in handy currently with
corona we've been printing
these masks so we don't print this
plastic visor but we print the headpiece
and the bottom clip here we're sending
these pieces out to
hospitals so that they can you know
protect people if there was 3d printers
when i was a kid
i would be all about it and geeking out
it'd be probably more important than
legos to me but
i mean you can kind of 3d print legos
i've done it
this is an essential item for me this is
a boosted board
i'm either biking or boosted boarding
around my neighborhood to go pick up
groceries
or just to entertain myself or my kids
i'll put one kid in the front
one kid in the back and we'll just sit
on the ground what's great is over the
years i've i've had every version of the
boosted board so i have
three of them and so i can go out with
two other friends and just do a little
brainstorm session while we're boosted
boarding
these things go a deadly speed uh i've
taken some pretty bad falls on it myself
i've never clocked it but i do ride it
12 miles to my work
and i book it so take the bike path
[Music]
these are some of my rc airplanes when i
get into a hobby
i'm kind of like my dad where i go
really deep into the hobby and so
i started with these maybe 10 or 12
years ago
and then quickly was escalating up to
these guys and then
bigger wingspans and eventually i got my
own pilot's license
i fly both rc and real
single-engine aircraft you know there's
so much more stakes when you're flying
a single engine aircraft with a friend
or a family member so you can't mess
around and do loops and like i'm gonna
go
dive down this tree and see if i can
make it like you only get one chance at
that so
again i think that's why i enjoy the rc
aircraft
i actually fly with my kids i have two
remotes so
i give them each remote and then i have
the master remote and so they think
we're working together but
it's really dad flying someday they're
gonna watch us and find out
their dad was flying the whole time
one of the most important items that i
have is my epipen the reason this item
is important
is because i'm super allergic to bees
and i'm a beekeeper so let me get my
suit
so this is what i wear when i'm
beekeeping
it's a pretty thick material and what it
allows you to do is be out by the bees
you have a little smoker
and the bees will come on you and and
some of them will try to sting you but
they usually can't get through this
thank goodness because i was told after
my first sting that landed me in the er
that i was highly allergic and all i
needed was to get stung like in the neck
area
which would uh potentially cause me to
stop breathing but over the years i've
learned how to actually beekeep and
it's fun you get some
beautiful works of nature it's really
honey is kind of art
so i absolutely love beekeeping i do
with one of my best friends
i think i'll be keeping the rest of my
life even though i i don't know if my
wife is a major fan of it
because of the allergy to bees
these are my essential three books
currently that i've been reading a lot
of
this book big magic is by elizabeth
gilbert incredible read if you want to
figure out
how to go about a creative lifestyle a
lot of little good nuggets of gold
and then another book with a lot of
wisdom for artists is the artist way by
julia cameron highly recommend
a lot of cool practical tactile habits
to
try out and see if it works for you the
other thing people ask me where i get my
ideas and i actually have a very similar
mind to gary larson i think his work is
genius and brilliant
i'll pull out some of his comics and
read just a couple pages
of one of the far side collections not
only makes me laugh but like i'll get
video ideas
my thing with reading is i usually get a
book
and i'll read it through or skim it and
take little sections and then kind of
digest it by
a chapter so for example in the artist
way she talks about different things you
can try out for a year and different
habits you can put into your lifestyle
i will try them um for usually a month
at a time
so i'll try it out for a month and if it
seems like it's working i'll commit to
another longer period of time like three
months or six months
that's what i love about reading you can
skim grab a little nugget try it out in
your life and see if it works and then
if not
move on and continue sorting through all
the other great literature out there
[Music]
this is my canon 5d i absolutely love
this series
this is the mark iv but this is one of
the cameras that changed the game for me
when it came to filmmaking
i got the mark ii when i was uh in high
school and
i absolutely like it changed the way the
depth of field looked in my work it felt
cinematic all of a sudden
and i think canon makes some beautiful
glass as well i spend
a lot of my time looking through
viewfinders i realize probably
many days of my year is actually just
looking through a viewfinder but i think
it's special because it's your way of
seeing the world and how you want it
there's
a million ways you can film this room
even but i get to put
my version out there in the world this
is also my home video camera so
i'll shoot my family videos with the 5d
and i know it looks annoying in public
now it's funny i like look like a
youtuber which is a dead giveaway but
i'm not vlogging i'm just
making my home videos my kids are funny
when they see me with the camera
they always say cheese so they think i'm
taking photos but
i'm like guys i'm i got all these videos
of you saying that now
[Music]
so this is an amazing set of tools this
bug hunting kit especially if you have
kids like i do
you've got your little your grabber and
we go bug hunting all weekend saturday
sunday
and sometimes after i come home from
work this is a super fun activity
especially here in california there's a
lot of fun insects and bugs and toads
that you can catch
but this is a super special bug
container because it allows you to catch
some really neat creatures that you may
not see with the visible eye
like this tarantula here
do we know if this one's poisonous how
do you know if they're how do you know
if they're poisonous
this is uh kind of terrifying
yeah we're gonna cut to the next thing
i carry around with me all day every day
one of these
a moleskin notebook i go through about
one every three weeks and i write down
everything from what i'm gonna do that
day i'm gonna write down ideas that come
to me
it's really helpful for me to get the
ideas on paper
and i know there's a lot of different
theories on this from different
creatives they'll say like oh well
good ideas you should always remember
them and don't write them down but i
found that's
with me never i just can't remember or
recall the cool thing about these
notebooks too
is you can flip to a page
[Music]
make your ideas come to life
[Music]
well thanks for hanging out and checking
out my essentials i'll see you guys next
[Music]
time